[MUSIC PLAYING]
MORGAN MCLEAN: We're all here
from the OpenCensus community.
I work at Google,
Sergey's from Microsoft,
and Steve is from a stealth
mode startup called Omnition.
We also have a few
people in the audience.
So we have some members of
the OpenCensus team here,
most notably Bogan Drew,
who's the team mascot.
And he's sitting over there.
So we'll bring people up
for questions at the end.
So, I'm guessing
that most of you
already know what OpenCensus is.
For those who don't,
OpenCensus is a set
of instrumentation libraries--
a little bit more than
that, but, at its core,
the project is a
set of libraries.
These libraries allow you to
extract distributed traces
and metrics from
your applications.
They take care of things
like context propagation, tag
propagation, and
basically all the things
you need to do to
get observability
with distributed traces and
metrics out of your app.
OpenCensus is somewhat
unique in the market.
It's not just an API.
It's an actual full
implementation.
So we maintain a
single distribution
of these libraries.
There's one for Java,
there's one for Node,
there's one for C++, and so
on, so that we can ensure all
of the functionality that
you expect to need is there.
One of the really interesting
parts with OpenCensus
is how you get the
data to your back end.
So as I mentioned, it's
just a set of libraries.
We don't do distributed
trace analytics.
We don't do metrics
analytics like projects
like Prometheus or Jaeger.
We simply allow you to
capture those because that's
a very difficult problem.
So we have this concept in
OpenCensus called exporters.
Exporter is the way
that you send the data
from your application
with OpenCensus
to your back end of choice.
So it's the way you
collect traces--
it's the way you pass on traces
to something like Jaeger.
It's the way you pass on metrics
to something like Prometheus.
So, if we have a sample
microservices app,
in this case, we have
the front-end service,
payment service, cart
service, and we're
calling a database API.
In this case, we have
OpenCensus linked inside
of our code for each
of these services.
It provides the APIs we need.
And it has the instrumentation
that will, in most cases,
automatically capture traces,
do context propagation,
capture critical metrics.
And by linking it there,
we'll capture traces
from these requests flows
that go through our service.
And then we'll send this data
to our back end via the exporter
interface that I
mentioned earlier.
One of the interesting
things about exporters
is that you can export to
multiple back ends at once.
This means you can export
to the tracing back end
and the metrics back end.
It also means that you can
export to multiple tracing
and metrics back ends
at the same time.
This is useful if
you're evaluating
a new vendor or
open-source project
that you're using as a back end.
It's also useful if you
have different teams who
are using different tools.
You can still get
that full stack
observability with like
Jaeger and Stackdriver,
for example, or Prometheus
and Stackdriver, for example.
With that, I'm going to
hand it over to Sergey.
SERGEY KANZHELEV: I'll
seize back for second.
You can count how many languages
this distributed app has.
And, like, four.
And this became a reality.
And to build OpenCensus
SDK all these languages
is a tricky task.
So with OpenCensus,
we're doing that.
And I'm happy to tell that for
four languages, Java, Golang,
Node.js, and Python,
we'll announce production
readiness this month.
For all other languages, it's
coming shortly after that.
So what does it mean
to build OpenCensus
for a single language?
We want to make sure that
it feels natural for you
to call with OpenCensus
on your language.
The same time, you want to
preserve all the terminology.
And also, look and
feel of OpenCensus SDK
across all the languages
so it's easy for you
to switch back and forth.
We also strive for
standardization
across languages.
So let's say your distributed
trace goes from one component
to another component.
You shouldn't know that
one component is Golang
and the other component .NET.
You just know that it will
be correlated magically.
So we'll see telemetry
from both components,
and it will be magically
linked together.
We also strive to
standardize data we collect
from all those languages.
I mean, it's not--
it became increasingly
important for you
to know that you can go
and look at telemetry
from an application code,
of which you don't know,
because it may be like
your dependent service,
or service you depend on.
And you are DRI in the
middle of the night,
and you need to look at
telemetry for your sister team
application.
And we strive for
standardization.
I mean, this standardization
is basically,
you shouldn't worry about
setting a load on a response
quote for HTTP for
the application
and language you don't know.
It's a response code for HTTP.
You shouldn't care.
And we worked on this API
stabilization and testing
for many languages.
And one thing I want to
talk about is integrations.
This OpenCensus SDK--
we want to make sure
that it can express your
application pattern, whatever
you use in your application.
Like, it may be
simple REST call,
or it may be fancy task
synchronization with a Redis
and database calls, and you can
synchronize it all together.
Or it may be some highly
efficient, queue-based RPC
protocol between your component.
And with OpenCensus,
we want to make
sure you can express all
that in a simple manner.
And to enable that
and to make sure
that you can do all
those integrations,
we created automatic data
collections for technologies.
Like for Java, for instance,
we support HTTP, GRPC, JDBC,
MongoDB, Jetty, Serverlets.
With the stabilization
of APIs and announcement
of the production rate, we
expect way more integrations.
And integration is
easier to enable--
like, single-gesture way to
enable monitoring and data
collection from
those components.
So what's missing
on other languages?
And-- oh, it's big checkboxes.
So on the OpenCensus.io,
we track detailed map
of all the features
and capabilities
of every single language.
So you can go
check it out there.
Here, I show bird's-eye
view on what's enabled
and what's supported.
You can see that metrics
API is lagging behind.
And it's not a surprise
because metrics API was just
introduced recently.
We were working on that with
OpenMetrics CNCF project.
And it just was
introduced recently,
and we already have
integration for four languages.
And if you've been on Morgan's
presentation from last year,
I want to emphasize
how much progress we've
made over a year.
I mean, this matrix
was nowhere near that.
And we made the commitment
to make four languages up
to parity, like, four--
all the main features.
And let's use that.
So you see all the checkboxes--
four coincide there.
So while we're working
on feature parity
on all other languages and
treat it as a high priority,
we also hear feedback
that you need
more signals for observability.
And one of the biggest
feedback is you need logging.
So we started working
on logging as well.
Logs is a very important
observability signal.
You need logs to troubleshoot.
And logs are very easy to
write, easy to collect, easy
to consume, unless it's not.
And it's not because
your application
tend to become more complex,
high-scale, and consists
of too many components
written by different vendors.
And this all
affects how you log.
With the scale comes the cost.
It became increasingly
costly to enable logs,
so you turn them off.
With complex business
logic, you have hard time
to navigate logs and make sense
of why does this log message
come after that log message?
It doesn't make sense.
And with the increased
number of components
it consume, all the
logs look different,
so you have hard time to
correlate them and understand
what's going on.
So we have a plan to
address all those problems.
We will start with a
correlation of logs.
And today, you already
have correlation and tags
for distributed traces.
Pretty soon, you'll be able
to use the same correlation
and tagging to group
and scope your logs.
And then we plan
to address some--
our promise is cost.
With the collector, you
will be able to do scenarios
like sending verbose logs for
only distributed traces that
had errors in them.
And you can do it
with retroactive
sampling when you cache
all the informations
and only send subset
of information
that is most important for
you across all your components
distributed across
multiple languages.
Then we want to do scenarios
like a sampling based
on verbosity of your logs.
You may want to collect only
20% of information logs,
and errors and
warnings all the time.
That's the kind of
scenarios we want to enable
for you to address cost issues.
And that can be done
on an OpenCensus Agent
or even directly in SDK.
And then lastly, we will--
maybe it's a longer
term goal, but we
want to provide better logging
API so you can log consistently
and responsibly.
Consistently means that--
I mean, our mean
bar is very low.
Like, you want to make sure
that computer name reported
by one system is the computer
name reported by another system
so you can correlate
those two computer names.
What we want ultimately
is to make sure
that we can help you mark up
some log messages as critical,
like containing password
information, or other PI
information, like personally
identifiable information,
like an IP address.
So we can warn you that
you're doing something strange
and you need to be
very careful with that.
And going forward,
you have more signals.
Like beyond logging,
we have more ideas
what needs to be
introduced in OpenCensus
and what needs to
be standardized.
And I keep saying
standardization
across languages,
of signals, standardization
with the new ideas.
And why standards
are important is
because we want every
library, every application,
and every platform to take
dependency up on OpenCensus
and make sure that the
observability comes out
of the box with every component.
And to do that, we need to--
this library right is to
trust us, and make sure
that it's a true standard.
We have another project in
CNCF doing the same thing,
doing standardization
across distributed tracing.
It's called OpenTracing.
And I am happy to tell
that we already announced
we're merging projects.
This is a big deal.
Everybody was asking about
difference between OpenCensus
and OpenTracing.
There are differences,
but it's better together.
And this merger is
not about one project.
And this merger is about merging
community of same-minded people
who want to work together to
build standards for monitoring
and to make sure
that the monitoring--
you take monitoring
for granted when
you deploy your application.
It's a full merger.
I mean, we'll announce
new name for the project.
And we'll announce [INAUDIBLE]
for all the libraries.
And all those announcements will
probably come in Kubernetes--
KubeCon conference,
Europe, end of May.
Another announcement
we want to make,
and as a true
open-source community,
actually we're working
on standardization
in the external bodies like W3C.
And next Monday,
we target declaring
that the specification of
the trace context going
into a candidate
recommendation stage.
Candidate recommendation
is the stage
when you can start using this
specification production.
With that, I'd be talking about
data collection standardization
SDKs for a long time.
And we're not only making
progress on that front,
we're also making
a lot of progress
on Agent and Collector side.
And Morgan will talk
more about that.
MORGAN MCLEAN: Thanks, Sergey.
So, we've started talking
the last few months
about some additional
components to OpenCensus.
As I mentioned earlier
in the presentation,
OpenCensus at its
core, and certainly
from the beginning of the
project, is a set of libraries
that you link to
your application.
But we have more today.
So starting a few months
ago, we began development
of the OpenCensus Agent.
This is an application that you
can run on each of your VMs,
or run as a DaemonSet
in Kubernetes,
that will collect traces and
metrics from the OpenCensus
libraries.
So your libraries will export
them to the OpenCensus Agent,
and which in turn will
then re-export them
to your back end of choice.
One of the big, big benefits
of the OpenCensus Agent
is that you can
choose and change
your exporters to your
back end without having
to redeploy your app.
This is particularly
big for platforms,
so certainly inside of Google.
For GKE, if we wanted
to use OpenCensus
to show traces and metrics
that come from the GKE platform
itself, this was a requirement.
We don't have customers rebuild
Kubernetes for themselves.
But it's also useful for
your own applications, right?
It's generally pretty annoying
with OpenCensus, or even
OpenTracing, which
Sergey mentioned.
Both of them today require you
to recompile, rebuild, redeploy
your app to change exporters.
With the Agent, you
no longer have to.
The second thing we have is
the OpenCensus Collector.
This is based off of the Agent.
It's, in some sense,
a version of the Agent
that is running as a
network service, typically
a service inside of Kubernetes.
The Collector will work to take
in all the traces and metrics
from your application.
They'll be sent
to the Collector.
And because they're all
sent to that central source,
in addition to
allowing you to change
your exporters in real time
like you can with the Agent,
the Collector will also
allow you to do things
like tail-based sampling.
And so, that means instead
of randomly sampling traces,
you can choose to
just send traces
for high-latency requests,
requests of errors,
to your back end.
This is a big, big
deal for people
who do distributed
tracing because it means
that the sampling that a
lot of customers do at 1%
is suddenly much more effective.
And Steve's going to do a
demo of that in a few minutes.
Now, cutting to my
laptop, we also, today,
are showing off a new feature
of the OpenCensus Agent
that we haven't
presented before.
So the OpenCensus Agent,
because it's running on every VM
or is a DaemonSet on
Kubernetes, can also
collect system metrics.
This is something we just added
right before the conference,
but it's now there
in the source code.
And, ah, it went to sleep.
And so, what we've got
here is Stackdriver.
This could be Prometheus.
This could be any
metrics back end.
It would effectively
be the same.
And we've got the
OpenCensus Agent
running on a number of our VMs
for the hipster shop demo app.
And we're collecting CPU time
for the system CPU time, user
CPU time, idle time,
and information
about all the processes
running on those machines.
This is coming from
the OpenCensus Agent.
It's collected directly
from that machine--
or from those
machines, actually.
There's multiple.
This is a big, big
vision into where
we're going to be in a few
months with the OpenCensus
Agent.
Our goal, or our
plan, is to also
have it be a great place
to collect all the system
metrics that you need from
things like collectd, statsd,
and so on.
And so by deploying
this OpenCensus Agent
to each of your VMs by pushing
out the OpenCensus libraries
to each of your
applications, you
can now get application
telemetry and system
telemetry that are
correlated and sent
to your back end of choice.
This is pretty easy to deploy.
I'm not going to go into
depth, but what I can show
you here is the
exporter configuration.
So this is inside
one of the services
that already has the OpenCensus
library linked to it.
You simply configure the
OpenCensus Agent exporter,
point it at the agent.
And then we have a YAML file
that deploys the OpenCensus
Agent as a DaemonSet.
It's really, really simple.
The images are
already pre-baked,
so you can just use
them, and it unlocks
a ton of powerful functionality
that we haven't had before.
We'll switch back to the slides.
And with that, I'm
going to give you Steve.
He's going to give you a great
demo of the OpenCensus Agent
and Collector.
STEVE FLANDERS: Thanks, Morgan.
All right, so we've talked
a lot about OpenCensus.
There's different pieces here.
We have the client libraries,
we have the OpenCensus Service.
So now, I actually
want to demonstrate how
you can leverage this power.
Let's start with the
client libraries.
So first, let's assume I want
to instrument an application.
I'm going to use a
Java application here.
And I know it's early, so we'll
walk through this line by line.
You don't have to
try to figure it out.
But how would you go ahead
and add instrumentation
to your code so you can take
advantage of, let's say,
distributed tracing
in this case?
So first, you need to
instantiate a tracer.
Basically, this allows
you to manipulate and add
additional metadata about
the types of interactions
between your microservices, or
even your function-level calls.
Next, you need to export
this to a back end.
It doesn't matter
what back end that is.
Here, I'm using Zipkin.
It can be any
exporter destination.
I'll talk about the
ones that are supported
by OpenCensus in a little bit.
Next, you determine
your sampling policy.
By default, OpenCensus
samples 1 in 10,000 traces.
If you want to do something less
aggressive, you can do that.
In this case, for demo purposes,
I'm sampling everything.
Clearly, at scale, that
may not make sense.
But for the purpose
of demonstrations,
that's pretty straightforward.
Those three lines are
really the only things
that you need to
configure globally
for each of your languages.
So in the case of Java here,
I can go ahead and throw this
into my common library
and then reuse it
across my application stack.
Then all I really need to do
is add the instrumentation
to the calls that I'm
making between my services.
Now for demo purposes,
there is a sleep in here.
That's because there's
actually batching being done.
And if you don't
wait long enough,
you wouldn't actually
see the traces.
That's why it's here.
But in your application, you
clearly wouldn't have that.
And then finally, here is
how you get a trace, right?
Here's the root span for
example, of a call coming in.
You can do the exact same thing
to create a child span as well.
So for each of your
function calls,
or at least between your
microservices calls,
you can go ahead
add instrumentation,
and that can help you
stitch together a trace.
It's really that
easy, all right?
There's not much to it.
In addition, you can
enhance these logs,
or enhance these traces,
with additional pieces
of metadata like logs.
So if you wanted
to-- for example,
if there was an error stack
maybe of a Java stack trace
that you want to include, you
can embed that into the span.
When you're creating
the span, you
can say if there is an
error, go ahead and tack
on that log message as well.
You can also add rich
metadata like key-value pairs.
So, you could add things
like, what region is
this service deployed in?
What version of the
code is it running?
And you can use this metadata to
actually get some rich insights
out of the data.
And I'll show that in a second.
So that's it from a client
library perspective.
Clearly it would be different
if you're using Go or Node
or what have you, but
there's good documentation
we have an OpenCensus.io
to help get you started.
If you already have your
own instrumentation,
that's fine as well, because
the OpenCensus Service actually
supports a wide variety
of formats today.
So as Morgan was talking
about, the OpenCensus Service
is really made up of two
different components, the OC
Agent and the OC Collector.
And you can choose to use
one, either, both, or neither.
It's really up to you.
It comes down to your
business requirements.
So here, I'm showing
some different topologies
of how you might deploy this.
The OC Agent can actually be
deployed with your application
as a binary.
It can be deployed as a
sidecar if you're using Docker.
It can be deployed
as a DaemonSet
if you're in the
Kubernetes world.
The Collector is a
standalone application
and can handle aggregation
of this data as well.
And of course, you have
the OC client library
which you can use as well.
Now, it doesn't matter how
you mix and mingle this.
Like, for example, as
Morgan was talking about,
you have different back ends.
Here, I have Zipkin,
Prometheus, and Omnition.
All right, well, maybe I don't
want to use Zipkin anymore.
I want to switch over to Jaeger.
It's just a
configuration change.
Everything else is
handled automatically.
Maybe I don't want to use the
OC library because I already
have instrumented in Jaeger.
No problem.
Jaeger is accepted by the Agent
and the Collector as well.
Let's say that I don't
want to use the Agent.
I just want to send
directly to the Collector.
That's fine.
I don't want to
use the Collector.
I only want to
send to the Agent.
That's fine.
But at the end of
the day, we would
recommend you leveraging
all the different components
because they provide
different value adds.
But you can choose to piece
this together however it makes
sense for your environment.
Now, some of the
values provided here
with the OpenCensus Service
you now only have to support
a single exporter destination.
So for example, if I'm using
the OC client libraries,
I can export and just
go, and I'm all set.
I don't have to worry about
writing that in Java and Node
in different languages.
That makes it much easier.
One thing to maintain,
one exporter.
That's really nice.
In addition, I can change
my back end whenever I want.
After I've instrumented and I've
sent to the OpenCensus Service,
it's a configuration
change to send my data
to a different location.
Whether I want to
replicate it so I send it
to two different back ends or
I want to switch back ends,
all that translation is
handled automatically for you
in the OpenCensus Service.
And the Collector
actually offers
some advanced
functionality, for example,
intelligent or tail-based
sampling-- the only
open-source solution today that
actually has that built in.
Redaction support-- you can
actually strip away tags
if, for whatever reason, there's
information there that you
don't want to be sharing.
You can tack on
additional metadata,
like region information.
Maybe you don't want to add that
into your application itself.
You could actually do
it from the Collector,
and actually say
all spans that are
being received
from this Collector
should have this region tag.
So there's a lot of
flexibility here depending
on the requirements that
you're trying to meet.
And really, the
OpenCensus Service
is about universal support.
So here are just a few
of the different types
of receivers and exporters
that are supported today--
a wide range.
And this OpenCensus Service
is extremely flexible.
You can actually
add more, and more
are being added all the time.
So it doesn't matter whether
you don't see your logo up here.
It can be added.
And you'll be able to
transform into and out
of these different formats.
So receivers are how you
get data into the system,
so either into the Agent
or into the Collector.
Exporters are how you get
data out of the system.
So all this translation is
handled for you automatically,
making it a truly
vendor-agnostic solution.
Now, one thing you
might be thinking about
is, OK, let's say I'm
using the Collector.
What about scale?
Does this thing actually scale?
The answer is yes.
We actually have
performance numbers
on the OpenCensus
Service GitHub page
that you can take a look at.
But as an example, we
have been testing it
at significant scale, for
example, 17.3 billion spans
a second.
That's equivalent to about
17.3 billion spans a day,
which is equivalent to about
200,000 spans a second.
That roughly accumulates
to 57 terabytes of data.
These were 3.3-kilobyte spans.
Span sizes can
vary anywhere from,
like, say, 100 to 200 bytes
up to maybe 10, 11 kilobytes,
depending on the number of
tags or the rich metadata
that you've added
there, with no drops.
And this was on a
single collector.
So typically, we're seeing
about 10,000 spans per second
for 1.2 cores of compute.
And this does scale linearly.
So you can make it as small
or as large as you want.
Another reason why you might
consider the Collector--
I talked a little bit
about intelligent sampling,
and Morgan mentioned it as well.
So there is a notorious problem,
if you will, with tracing,
and that is that it's
extremely verbose.
This is very similar
to logging, but there's
no verbosity level in tracing.
So you have a couple of options
on how to deal with this.
You can either try
to collect all of it.
At scale, that can be very hard.
Head-based sampling
is very common.
Basically when you're about to
create the initial root span,
you make a sampling
decision on whether or not
you want to actually
sample that request or not.
The problem with
head-based sampling
is that you don't
actually know what's
going to happen downstream.
You're making the decision
at the entry point.
So for example, maybe
the root span is fine,
but there was an
error down the stack.
You won't know if you didn't
actually sample that trace.
Tail-based sampling takes
the opposite approach.
It basically says, let me
collect the entire trace,
and then make a
sampling decision.
So you can actually do
some pretty cool things.
You can say, I only want
to sample error traces.
If any of the spans contain
an error, let's sample that.
You can do tag-based.
So you can look for certain
metadata in these spans
or in these traces, and then
make a sampling decision
based on that.
Or my personal favorite,
you can do something
like retrieval-based.
So you can actually say, let's
make a sampling decision.
Let's assume that a
trace was not sampled.
And then your back end
can say, hey, actually
I do need that trace.
Do you still have it?
And I can actually ask
the collector for it
and pull it out and
actually make sure
that it does get ingested,
or ensure that it's
ingested going forward.
We actually have a demo
of this, so you can
go ahead and take a look at.
It's all available
on the GitHub page.
So it's actually
a Docker Compose.
And I want to walk
through that real
quick with a demo, which I hope
will show up well on the screen
here.
Let's take a-- oop.
AUDIENCE: Nope.
STEVE FLANDERS: Do we switch?
AUDIENCE: It's still
part of the slide there.
STEVE FLANDERS: It's
part of the slide.
OK, yeah.
Can we switch back?
Perfect.
And let's try.
All right.
Actually, it looks pretty
good on a big screen.
I like this.
So, here is the
tail-based sampling demo.
Basically, it's a
Docker Compose file.
It's made up of a
configuration file
to deploy the Docker containers.
Here, there are going to be
two different Jaeger instances.
And then it has
the configuration
for the OpenCensus Service.
So we're basically configuring
two different destinations,
one to receive
only error traces,
and the other to receive both
error and non-error traces.
So we can go ahead
and fire this up.
You can run this
locally on your system.
You can deploy this into
your public cloud of choice.
It doesn't matter.
It will spin up a
Cassandra instance
with different key spaces
for the two Jaeger instances.
It will fire up Jaeger.
And then in the
OpenCensus world,
we use this hipster demo shop.
And there's actually a
load generator utility
that will go ahead and send in
traces from the hipster demo
shop and send that into the
OpenCensus Service, which
will then handle the splitting
of the traffic for you
automatically.
It takes a few seconds
to get spun up here.
And then you can go ahead and
navigate to 17,000 and 18,000.
That's the two different
Jaeger instances.
So, the first one receives all
of the traces, all of the spans
that are being received.
So here, we can take a
look at that cart service.
And you can see that
there are spans coming in,
but there are no
errors up there.
And if we look at
18,000, and again we
go look at the cart
service, you'll
see that we only
see error traces.
That's because we have
tail-based sampling enabled,
and we basically said we want
only traces that contain errors
to go to one destination,
we want everything
to go to the other.
It's very simple,
very easy to configure
with a YAML-based configuration.
All right, one more quick demo.
So let's tie this all together.
We have our client
libraries-- pretty easy
to get instrumented and started.
If you already have your
existing instrumentation,
you can leverage that.
We talked about the
OpenCensus Service
and how it's easy to get
data in and change it
into different formats so you
can switch different back ends
or take advantage of more
advanced functionality
such as tail-based sampling.
But what is really
the power of the data
that you get on the other end?
Now, OpenCensus is more than
just distributed tracing.
It's also metrics.
It's also logs.
But I'm going to show an
example with distributed
tracing because that's very
powerful in the cloud-native
world.
With microservice-based
architectures,
it's really critical to
understand how your system is
behaving, and so just looking
at individual symptoms
is typically not sufficient.
You want context
and correlation,
and that's what distributed
tracing can provide for you.
So we've talked a little bit
about the hipster demo app.
If you haven't seen
it before, here's
kind of a visual
representation of it.
Every rectangle here
represents a different service.
It's actually a
polyglot architecture.
So every one of these
boxes is written
in a different language.
This is available on GitHub,
so you can actually take it
for a spin and try it out.
And basically, we
want to demonstrate
what a request flow through
this system might look like.
So if you've ever used a
distributed tracing tool,
let's say Zipkin
or Jaeger, then you
may be familiar with
something similar to this.
It's just an actual trace.
So you actually see
the different calls
through a single request here.
Here, you can see
coming in the front end,
hitting the checkout
service, payment service,
a few other services.
So now I know the calls that
were made for certain requests
into my system.
I also get some information
about the duration of how long
those different operations took.
That can be useful from
a performance standpoint.
And for each of these, as
they're known as spans,
you actually have rich metadata.
So you can drill into it
and you can get information
about what that call did.
So in the case of,
like, RPC or REST calls,
you might get the status code.
I talked about tacking on
metadata to the collector.
So here, for example, you
can see region information.
Maybe you have build
information about your version
that you can tack on as well.
You can control how
much rich information
you want to include
in these spans.
But you can also do some
more interesting things
with distributed tracing.
And for that, I want
to show one more demo.
Yeah, all right.
So let's start here.
I'll pause it first.
So here is the hipster
demo app again.
This is built purely
from distributed traces.
So if you're receiving
traces from Zipkin or Jaeger
or the OpenCensus client
library, just distributed
tracing information, you can go
ahead and construct the hipster
demo shop.
And this is what it
would look like visually.
And you can see the different
calls that are happening.
And if there are errors
or problems with them,
they clearly stand out.
You can also get information
about the back end
databases or any other
platform services
that you're leveraging.
Now for this particular
example, let's assume
that you're hearing that
the recommendation service
and production is
having problems,
and you're being asked to
go ahead and investigate it.
So let's go ahead and
do that using only
distributed tracing information.
So I can go ahead and actually
click on the recommendation
service.
And I can get some
rich information
about the requests that
are being made here.
I see a lot of red.
That's probably bad.
But there's high
cardinality in my data.
Let me go ahead
and break it down
by the different
environments I have.
Well, now I can see that, yes,
only production has errors.
Stag and development is fine.
I can see that for
my different regions,
they're both receiving errors.
That doesn't give
me much information.
But I can also
see that a certain
build number, build 235--
that is the one that
is experiencing issues.
So very quickly, I can go and
say, I have a bad build here.
I need to go roll that back.
It's impacting my environment.
That's all with just
distributed tracing data,
not with metrics, not with logs.
That provides some rich
correlation and context
in a rich way to actually
divide my data up.
And I can actually
take this distributed
tracing information, and
let's say with the logging
spec that Sergey
was talking about,
you can tack on information like
the trace ID and the span ID.
And now I can actually
say, for a given trace,
show me all the logs for that
request, or from a given log,
go ahead and show me the
topology of how that actually
looks from a call
perspective in my environment
or my application.
It's very powerful.
And all this is enabled
through OpenCensus.
All right, so, call to action.
No presentation would
be complete without one.
Please join us.
There is a lot to do in
the OpenCensus community.
There are plenty
of client libraries
that we would love your help
on the OpenCensus Service.
We have several
GitHub issues open.
They're usually
pretty well labeled
with "help wanted" or
"good first issue,"
if you're interested
in contributing back.
Please go ahead and
join us on Gitter.
We have a Gitter community
where we actually
talk about OpenCensus publicly.
And if you're
interested in trying
more of the
intelligent sampling,
that's available as well.
All that is on GitHub.
And with that, I'll turn
it back over to Morgan.
MORGAN MCLEAN: Thank you.
That's fantastic.
So obviously, OpenCensus
is an open-source project.
It's a big one-- has
some heavy hitters in it.
Google created the project.
They're one of the
biggest contributors.
Microsoft's a huge
contributor, as is Omnition.
A big, big, growing community.
I'd be remiss to
forget about Postmates.
They developed the
entire Erlang library.
They make a ton of
other big contributions.
And there's a ton of other
smaller contributors.
When I was making this slide,
I was a little worried.
Like, I don't want
to leave out any
of the smaller contributions
from other groups.
These are just the sort
of the organizations that
have committed the most code.
We obviously a lot of
support for exporters
and back ends that you can
send data to with OpenCensus.
Most of those are maintained
by their respective bodies.
Datadog contributed an
exporter for Datadog.
I think Honeycomb built
their own, and so on.
Some of them were built by
the OpenCensus community.
But it's a big, big,
diverse ecosystem.
What we're excited
about today is
announcing that
another big company
has promised to make large
contributions to the project.
And so joining us
at this conference
and joining the OpenCensus
project is Dynatrace,
one of the world's biggest, and
I think the world's biggest APM
vendor.
And to talk about that,
we have Alois Reitbauer.
Hand this back.
ALOIS REITBAUER: Yeah, hello.
I'm Alois Reitbauer
from Dynatrace.
I'm leading op-- oh,
that's not the slide,
but yeah, it looks good though.
I'm leading open source
initiatives here at Dynatrace.
And I think we had our first
conversation about a year ago.
And interestingly, very
much from the beginning,
I think we have
around the same--
had the same ideas on
how this should evolve,
and that we should really all
collaborate around collecting
trace data, and that we
all have our own back
ends that provide our own
benefits to our customers.
And also for us at Dynatrace,
well, a couple of years
back, we started to focus more
on AI and analytics, obviously,
having the input data.
And we want to give
all our customers
all of the flexibility to
augment their data with what
you can get via OpenCensus.
And I think in the next slide--
ah, yeah.
Thank you.
So, this is actually a preview
that I have taken directly
out of our development
process here.
What you can see
here is actually
OpenCensus data in Dynatrace.
So we are now on weekly calls
with the OpenCensus team,
with respectively Google
and Microsoft here,
where our focus is really
that we provide OpenCensus
data as first-class
citizens within Dynatrace,
and also providing
our input, especially
around type span
builders who have
high-level APIs for OpenCensus.
[MUSIC PLAYING]